الامريكي المتخصص في الشؤون الاسيويه
وتحديدا العلاقات الامريكيه الروسيه لخص
ابرز الخلافات بين القطبين الاعظم في
العالم عسكريا في كلمتين اتنين فقط
او معضله الامن من وجهه نظره ان كل الطرف
من الطرفين الامريكي والروسي بيعتبر الطرف
الاخر مصدر للتهديد وبالتالي بيتخذ
اجراءات لحمايه مصالحه وامنه القومي هذه
الاجراءات تستفز الطرف الاخر وبالتالي
بيتخذ اجراءات مضاده ومماثله فيزداد
التوتر وتزداد حده الصراع بين البلدين
زجلر حدد ملفات محدده بتثير الخلاف بشكل
اساسي بين البلدين
ثلاث ملفات من وجهه نظر الروس وخمس ملفات
من وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده الروس
قلقانين من الملفات الثلاث التاليه الاول
هو تفوق الولايات المتحده في الاسلحه
التقليديه التي تطورها بشكل مستمر وبشكل
يقلق الروس اتنين توسع الولايات المتحده
او حلف شمال الاطلسي شرقا وبالتالي هذا
التوسع شرقا من حلف شمال الاطلسي او
النيتو روسيا بتعتقد ان الهدف النهائي منه
هو تطبيق روسيا
والملف الثالث والاخير هو رغبه الولايات
المتحده وسعيها الدائم في تغيير الانظمه
خصوصا الصديقه لروسيا تحت دعاوى دعم
الديمقراطيه
الولايات المتحده عندها خمس ملفات تقلقها
من السياسات الروسيه الملف الاول هو تركيز
روسيا على تطوير ترسانتها من الاسلحه
النوويه الملف الثاني سعيها الدائم لتقويض
النظم الليبراليه والديمقراطيه بما فيها
نظام الحكم في الولايات المتحده طب وهي
روسيا ممكن تقود الانظمه الديمقراطيه ازاي
الامريكان بيتهمون بالتدخل في انتخابات
مثلا سنه 2016 في الولايات المتحده التي
اتت بترامب بيتهموا روسيا بمحاوله التلاعب
في الراي العام الاوروبي بحيث ياتي ذلك
باحزاب وقوه يمينيه قوميه متطرفه معاديه
للقيم الديمقراطيه وتسعى لتفتيت الاتحاد
الاوروبي على سبيل المثال
الملف الثالث الذي يخلق الامريكان هو
استعداد الروس للتدخل وانتهاك سياده بعض
الدول المجاوره ابرز مثال الان هو
اوكرانيا الملف الرابع دعم الروس للدول
المارقه مارقه على مين مارقه على الاراده
الامريكيه ابرز مثالين الان ايران
وفنزويلا والملف الاخير هو التطور المستمر
في العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه التي تعتقد
الولايات المتحده ان هذا التطور سوف يضر
بمصالحها على المدى القريب والمدى البعيد
في القلب من كلمه معضله امنيه هو عدم
الثقه يعني السبب الرئيسي في المعضله
الامنيه لما تتامله هو عدم الثقه او
المسترست لا يوجد ثقه بين روسيا وبين
الولايات المتحده
وهي عالم الثقه مهم في العلاقات الدوليه
بالغ الاهميه في العلاقات الدوليه كما انه
بالغ الاهميه في العلاقات الانسانيه
الدول زي الافراد بتعقد كثير من الاتفاقات
عسكريه وامنيه تجاريه وغير تجاريه كل هذه
الاتفاقات بتقوم على اساس الثقه في ان
الطرف الاخر سوف يوفي بتعهداته ليه
بيعتمدوا على الثقه لان ما فيش قوه كبرى
فوقيه تستطيع ان تجبر دولتين او عده دول
على الالتزام باتفاقاتها الشيء الوحيد
اللي بيخلي الدول توقع الاتفاقات العسكريه
والمدنيه هو الثقه ليس اكثر اذا غابت
الثقه بتنهار كل الاتفاقات وتتوتر
العلاقات الدوليه الحروب بتقوم لاسباب
كثيره عدم الثقه سبب رئيسي في قيام كثير
من الحروب دوله بتراقب تحركات دوله اخرى
بتقراها بشكل سلبي بشكل عدواني وبتعتقد ان
هذه التحركات بتستهدفها فتبادر بالهجوم او
العدوان فتبدا الحروب والامثله
لا تقع تحت حصر